FRIEDMAN: Hello.
Welcome.
It is September 14th, 2022
and we're in ActInf Livestream
number 48.2.
Welcome to the Active
Inference Institute.
We're participatory online institute
that is communicating,
learning and practicing
applied active inference.
You can find us
at some of the links on the slide.
This is a recorded
and an archived livestream,
so please provide feedback
so we can improve our work.
FRIEDMAN: All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome here
and we'll follow
video etiquette for livestreams.
Head over to active inference
dot org to learn more about
how to participate in learning
groups and projects
such as livestreams and others.
Well, we are in our third discussion
around this paper
"Communication as Socially Extended
Active Inference: A Ecological Approach
to Communicative Behavior"
from 2021
by Remi Tison and Pierre Poirier.
and last week in 48.1
FRIEDMAN: with
FRIEDMAN: the very same
fellows in the conversation,
we had some explorations into
different aspects of the paper.
Perhaps we can each say hello again
and something if we want to,
that we remember from last week,
or that we'd like to explore today.
And then we can just be right in it.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm in California
and I'm interested to look towards
the latter
half the back nine of the paper
and see where we go,
which is kind of what we do
in Dot Two's usually.
FRIEDMAN: And I just have a feeling that
the exit from the slide on this one
may put our communication
and situated ness in a different place
than where we were before.
And I'll pass it to
KNIGHT: Bleu.
DEAN: Hi! I'm Bleu.
FRIEDMAN: I heard the initial part and
KNIGHT: then lost it, Bleu.
KNIGHT: You happen to hear me now?
Yeah, I am a Bleu
and I'm a researcher in New Mexico
and I am excited to dig
back in to this paper.
I think we left
a lot of things
to wonder about last week and and yeah,
excited to get to maybe more
into the meat of the paper itself
as opposed to just
discussing tangential ideas.
KNIGHT: And I'll pass to Dean.
DEAN: DEAN TICKLES: Thanks Blue.
DEAN: I'm I'm here in Calgary.
I'm interested in
seeing whether or not
the big road map
that I think that
this paper provides
also can be explained as a big score, as
as in a
kind of a musical analogy,
because I'm really interested in the,
in the interplay
or the interaction
between orchestration and arrangements.
We yesterday
there was a math string
that where our guest was
really good at sort of
describing the arrangement part of
of what's going on
and active inference potentially.
DEAN: And so I'm really kind of interested
in looking at that
because
I think from a transmission versus
ecological standpoint,
we're kind of looking at the difference
between mono and stereo.
So I'm wondering if we should maybe
look at that through that lens as well.
TISON: Hi, I'm Remi Tison.
I I'm though I'm
a researcher at Cannes in Montreal
and I'm the author of the paper,
and I'm looking forward
to discussing the paper more in detail
and maybe go to
towards the later parts of the paper
and maybe talk about a bit
about the language
and linguistic communication,
which is a big piece
that is looming behind the paper,
but it's not really
that much discussed in it,
but I think that's the way to that.
TISON: That's what
TISON: an account of communication aims to
go towards.
So I hope we'll have
the chance to discuss it a little bit.
FRIEDMAN: Let's go to language.
It's what we're using,
FRIEDMAN: among other modalities.
But we are using language and
so that sounds like a
great place to start.
So what was in the paper
regarding language
and what was not in the paper regarding
language?
TISON: Yeah. So
the the idea
was to open a window
at the end of the paper
towards that language.
So we talked a bit about conventional
forms of communication and we know that
most people believe
that language is conventional.
So we tried to tie
the are are
the ideas that we put forward
in the paper with work by Hampstead
in a paper of 2016
about conventional affordances.
TISON: So we tried to say that
that the linguistic community,
the conventional nature of the language
comes
from the
conventional affordances
that are generated in the, in the,
the communicative interaction.
So that's what,
that's the
way to point
toward language in our account.
And
we talked a bit about the act.
So different types
of active language, so
informative or
or declarative
and interrogative imperative.
TISON: So these kinds of distinctions,
we try to account for them
in our framework.
So are these are various parts
of what we considered
to be language
that we tried to treat in the paper.
But there's a lot of things
that we
couldn't discuss, obviously,
because it was like in the
in the small section
and the
at the end we cannot like explain
all of language.
TISON: Yeah.
TISON: Even in their paper or in their book
and so,
so in the small section,
that would be obviously way
too ambitious.
FRIEDMAN: What are we looking to explain
or what is needed for language to be
encompassed or at home
or native to the ecological view,
rather than the transmission view,
or in addition to the transmission view?
Read me first then others.
TISON: Yeah.
TISON: A point that is interesting is that
the transmission view comes with the
opposition about what
has to be explained by a theory of
of language.
It comes with the idea
that we have to account for the meaning
of the
the expressions that are used first.
So we have to understand
whether the meaning
of the words that we use and how
these meanings
are encoded
in the, in the brains
and the heads of the
of the speakers of other language.
TISON: But that's
misleading from the point of view
that we adopt in the papers.
So this it's kind of hard to say
what we have to explain
in order to explain
language, because for so long
we have based in
we have
been in the the the transmission view.
And so we are used to believe
that in order to explain language,
we have to explain these kinds
of contents.
TISON: That language transmits so
but if we do away with these contents,
it's kind of the open the question of
how do you account for language.
It becomes kind of open in a new way.
And I don't really know
exactly what we have to account
for in order to account for language,
because it kind of changes
our view of what language is.
So I think there's a lot of open space
in there in this question of
how do we account for language
if we do away
with the transmission, you.
FRIEDMAN: D or blue.
DEAN: You got blue.
KNIGHT: So I just looked,
looking back over the paper,
I think it might be useful to
maybe delineate the the specific types
of language interactive
versus imperatives
and like the specific,
the specificities underlying
each one of those right now
that that would be maybe a good place to
to just dove into the meat of the paper.
FRIEDMAN: So
how can we see
these different types of speech?
Speech acts
as shaping the field of affordances.
What is being done ecologically
with these different speech behaviors
as opposed to the
enabling aspect
of the transmission view?
I think they're fairly clear
within the transmission view
what these statements are about.
And as you pointed out, it's
almost like hard to escape
viewing
what these speech behaviors are
by the content,
like if not their content
quite literally,
then what would they be about?
FRIEDMAN: Even talking about what they're about,
but informative would be sharing
a proposition, an or a some reducing
some of the uncertainty about the state
of something in the world.
I'm feeling this way or that way.
Is this much
and so on for other statements,
because indeed
they're defined by the content
and their structure.
So ecologically,
I mean, what might these types
of speech behaviors be doing?
TISON: So these
these types of active language
are well accounted for in their
in the transmission view.
But there are some questions
that remain
about
the imperative form of communication,
because it's it's not clear
that interactive communication
can be understood
as a form of transmission of content,
because we have the feeling that when we
come in something
or request something, we are not
transmitting information
or we are not
aiming at changing
the mental states of the person
that we are talking to.
TISON: We are aiming at making them
do something in the world directly.
So so there is
there's kind of a mismatch there,
it seems.
So obviously
people in the transmission
you will evidence or they will say that
like when I have,
for instance, that desire
or the intention
that something is the case,
I then an imperative
act of communication
is my transmitting this intention
or this desire
to that person that we then
as this desire or this intention,
and then can bring
about the state of affairs
that I intend to achieve.
TISON: But it's not I'm not sure.
Obviously, you can delve into details,
but I'm not sure that's
exactly what we want to do.
When we
state we
when we produce an imperative active
language, obviously we won't.
We just
don't just want that the person
as the intention of doing something.
We want the thing done in the world.
So I believe that the imperative
kind of communication
is not really
well accounted
for in the transmission view.
TISON: And what's interesting is that in a way,
the imperative form of communication
is like
the basic form
of communication in our framework,
because that what's what a communication
is, is acting through the behavior
of somebody else,
by affecting its field of avoidance
so that we can we can go back to, like,
the forms of animal communication
that we describe earlier in the paper.
TISON: And these are all
TISON: can all be considered
to be
imperative forms of comedy or proto
imperative forms of communication.
So that's like the starting point.
And we,
we achieve these acts under the purview
of somebody else
by altering their field of affordances
to make them something, to do something.
But how do we account
for informed, informative
acts of communication?
TISON: And an idea
that we put forward in the paper
is that an informal
the kind of
acts of communication
that that we consider to be informative
will be acts that aim to construct
or alter a shared field of affordances
in a way
that is more durable
than just an immediate
interactive act of language.
So what we are doing,
we are changing
the layout of the context
that we take for
to be relevance to our joint action.
TISON: And this is changing of affordances
do not have to be immediately
acted upon.
I can say, oh,
there's something in the in the context
that's relevant.
TISON: It does not necessarily call
for action immediately,
but it's something that is like
in the background
of our context of action.
And so it's change.
It changes
the shared field of affordances, but
it's not directly
soliciting an
action from the
interlocutor, as would be the case
for the imperative act of language.
TISON: So in a way,
it's like as this in the beginning,
an informative, active language is like
a long term imperative
or a dispositional imperative.
We put something in the context,
we say, Oh, that's relevant.
We can act on it at some point,
but it's not necessarily immediately
to be acted upon.
So that's how we can like put the,
the idea that, okay,
we can change our context of action,
what we can take
to be relevant in the context of action.
TISON: And we can come back to it
later when,
when it's relevant and act on it.
But it's not something
that is to be acted upon immediately.
And so that's like the, the,
the difference
between imperative and formative
begins to do to be
discerned there where an imperative is
like I'm
seeing that this, so
this affordances
should be acted upon immediately
and informative is like I'm
putting this in the context,
it changes the layout of affordances.
TISON: So for instance,
there would be
a, I don't know
if to come up with an example,
but if I inform you of something,
I'm putting
I'm changing the layout of the audience
that we take for granted
in the context of our interaction.
And it changes
in the long term, the interaction,
and it can like drive
the interaction in various ways,
but it's not something to be acted
directly immediately.
TISON: So that's the basic distinction.
And that's like the beginning
TISON: of a distinction
between informative and imperative.
And I can say a few words
about the interrogative too.
So as we said and,
and communication is acting
typically acting
through the behavior of somebody else
bye bye
by altering its field about audience
and the interrogative.
It's interesting
because it's exactly the distinction
between imperative and interrogative is
really similar to the
this distinction
between pragmatic value
and epistemic value
and active inference.
TISON: So, for instance,
when we produce an action
TISON: that aims to maximize pragmatic value,
we are trying to, for instance, do
to
make the state of the world correspond
to a prediction of our derivative model.
And when we make something
which is guided by epistemic value,
what we try to do
is trying to reduce in certain
uncertainty about our
our niche, for instance,
but so in a way, so for instance,
when I'm eating something, I'm,
I'm maximizing my,
my interest in my pragmatic value
because I'm, for instance,
reducing a prediction error
that I'm hungry and I want to.
TISON: So that's a basic example.
But when I'm exploring my environment,
TISON: when I'm making a visual
aid to explore my needs.
So that would be an epistemic
action, so to speak.
So interrogative
acts of language
are exactly analog to epistemic actions,
but they are epistemic actions
through the behavior of somebody else.
So instead of, for instance, by myself
exploring the niche, exploring the field
about audience, I can produce this act
that will make the other person
disclose to me
an element of the field of audience that
can then reduce my
uncertainty about
what is the context of our action.
TISON: So that's really the distinction
between interactive
and interrogative is really
to be understood
along the line of the distinction
between pragmatic value
and epistemic value.
So that's
a beginning to an introduction to these
these distinctions in the in the types
of acts of language.
KNIGHT: Don't start me.
KNIGHT: You totally you totally read my mind.
They're about what I wanted
to, to elaborate on,
even though my question
was like very partly framed.
Yeah,
I think that that's very useful for
especially in
like the goal directed
aspect of imperatives
versus interrogative or informative
like what,
how they interact with our maybe
we don't have a joint goal versus
we do have a joint goal
or the goal is to develop
some shared state
of a shared mental state.
KNIGHT: So that was really helpful.
KNIGHT: Thank you.
FRIEDMAN: Another note is that the informative
behavior is like
the base class of the transmission view
because it seems to be like it's
updating one on the details.
Like what
if I'm saying
there is a gallon of milk in the fridge?
Truly what else could be conveyed
other than the content?
So it seems like the most natural.
And then there are specific
kinds of content like
sharing the content
that you have a question
or sharing the content
that you would like somebody to act.
And so in that way, as you described,
many forms of speech behavior
are well accounted for
in the transmission view,
and that
accounting is actually kind
of a callback
to that mouth stream for David Spivak
about accounting system.
So these are like accounting models.
And then you highlighted that imperative
in the inactive and ecological view,
all communication that the imperative is
perhaps the basic form of communication,
and that can be seen developmentally
through a child
and the kinds of communications
that they may engage
in, as well
as from an evolutionary perspective,
with the kinds of audio or chemical
or physical stigma
and marks that different
kinds of creatures
use to communicate within
and across species.
FRIEDMAN: So those are action
oriented communications,
as we can
then say, all action
oriented communication
or all communication
we can say is action
oriented in an obvious way.
So then imperative becomes
the base class
shaping the field of affordances.
If that's what the ecological view on
communication is,
is going to be most natural
with kinds of expressions
that we can say are imperative.
FRIEDMAN: And then informative updates
are like
one step
removed from direct action requests.
So saying
turn the handle to
the left is an imperative.
If you said,
I'm going to
inform you about two things,
the handle can be turned to the left.
And if this happens,
you may want to turn the handle.
Those are breaking down a capacity
for action into sequential or modular
or re composable
statements.
FRIEDMAN: But those statements are like hiding
the consequences of action.
And so in that way, we
we can have an action
oriented view on communication
and then see different kinds of other
behavior as like
modified or truncated or censored
or hidden action modification.
And that may or may not entail needing
to even explain
how meaning is represented,
transmitted or received.
FRIEDMAN: Yes, from me.
TISON: That's exactly it.
TISON: So the that's really the
the idea extended very well.
And another example
that we that we often use here is the
the joint action of cooking a meal
with various people.
So like an example,
we use that in the last discussion,
the example of moving a couch
to another example
maybe to change a bit
our intuitions about communication.
TISON: So when people are cooking
a meal together,
we can suppose that some people,
some of the
so suppose
that we're in the kitchen
of one of the person
and the other doesn't know
exactly where all the things are.
And so at first the person could say
there's flour in there in the
in the cupboard or in the pantry
and saying that that's an important
and informative language.
TISON: But that could
that's like
that might be a hidden
imperative insofar as at some point
in the interaction
in the cooking of the meal,
the flour might be needed.
And at this point,
this alteration
of the field of affordances,
the appearance of the flour
as an affordances
in the context might drive
the action of the person
when the flour is needed.
TISON: At a certain point,
the person will have this software
dense field and will go to to to seek it
if it's necessary at that point.
So the informative is,
as I said,
something like a dispositional or long
term imperative.
So something of a hidden imperative
that can drive behavior
in the long term.
So so it's like at the beginning
this distinction is more
is a distinction of like
is this effort tends to be acted upon
immediately by you or
is it posed in the context
and can
like alter
the dynamic
without being directly
acted upon immediately.
TISON: So that's out there would be
the distinction is drawn.
And yeah, I,
I think that that's,
that's how we try to to
account for informative
without
describing it as
transmitting a content
or an information.
So that's that's the idea.
And I think that you explain it
very well in your in your in your your.
Yeah.
In your explanation.
FRIEDMAN: But yeah, it's very
interesting.
It's just another
consequence of centering action.
So many things, the pragmatic turn,
pragmatism earlier
than the so-called pragmatic
turn in the neurosciences
and all of the developments
in cognitive science.
In many cases, it's been like
an information or an inference view
yielding to an action view,
and that just played out
differently on different frontiers.
FRIEDMAN: And it feels like in a way,
language is like the stronghold
of information views
because it's like so amenable
to syntactic and discourse analysis
in a and composition ality
and all these features
that we see in formal models and in
computer systems
that it feels
like, oh, maybe
all the funny stuff
that people do and say,
we'll figure that one out to
Blue.
FRIEDMAN: And then Dean.
KNIGHT: So I just wonder about
like mimicry,
which is something that we see
like in the animal kingdom a lot.
And like whether that is imperative,
I mean, sometimes
I guess it can be imperatives like
watch me do this and then you do it,
but not always.
So sometimes it's like,
you know,
an animal,
we'll see another animal do something.
KNIGHT: And then they try it too.
And so what?
I don't know.
I just don't know how to look
at it
in the terms of teaching and learning
and like shared goal directness.
Like what is maybe the role of mimicry
and how does that like
what is the effect
on the field of affordances?
Does it just open up
like you see someone do something
and then your field of
affordances opens to
that is also possible for me?
KNIGHT: Or does that
not have maybe like a semantic analog?
I don't know.
KNIGHT: Yeah, that's a really good question.
And often people with either
TISON: the transmission view
will adopt the view
that the main driver
of the evolution of language in human
societies was the transmitting of
of knowledge and of skills,
for instance,
then of, of various types of activities.
So that's like a,
a clear example where it seems
that the transmission view
as a story to say
when, if we, if we take for granted
that like
in imitating somebody or, or,
or learning
something to somebody is in effect
transmitting a knowledge or a certain
kind of,
of, of mental state or cognitive state.
TISON: So there's clearly
something interesting there
for the transmission of you,
but I think that's
an alternative possible analysis.
You just heard that it is the idea
that you
when you're interacting with somebody
and specifically with somebody of your
of your own species,
seeing this person do
something can open
new affordances for yourself.
For instance,
if I see I see
somebody that looks like me
do something.
TISON: I'm I have learned that when
somebody looks like me, does something
usually be with a little bit of effort.
I can do it too.
So somebody doing
something is a way of opening,
opening up new affordances for me
and trying to achieve it.
So in many case,
mimicry will not
necessarily be communicative.
That is because an organism
can do something without.
TISON: I mean, no, it is not communicating
nothing to anybody,
but it happens
that somebody else watches it and
imitates it.
So in
that case,
there's not necessarily communication,
but in cases
where there is communication involved,
I think we can analyze and analyze it,
just as you said.
That is saying that
the action of the organism opens up
and you have far
for the person who's watching it,
doing it.
TISON: And usually in cases of explicit
TISON: skill learning, for instance,
the experts will like do the thing
more deliberately,
more slowly,
more explicitly to like show
what are the relevant movement
that has to be made in order to achieve
so that like
making more salient
the kind of, of the, of movement
that has to be made to, to,
to succeed in the
in performing their skill.
TISON: So I think that's a way
that we can understand
this kind of skill
learning in the transformation
of the affordances
that are available to the person
that's receiving the the communication,
that that's
how I would I think I would analyze it.
FRIEDMAN: One simple
example kind of building on this, making
certain actions deliberate,
then being interested for your thoughts,
even showing something deliberately,
verbally calling attention,
or just the position of the body
for a physical skill.
It shapes the field of affordances,
specifically where somebody can look.
So if you're like, okay, I'm
going to swing the bat
and then now I'm going to show you
what my hand
you know,
this isn't usually how I do it,
but I'm going to show you how
I was holding it at that time.
FRIEDMAN: You have shaped
their field
of ocular motor affordances and
and that is what enables
their generative model to update.
And so nowhere in that account is
I'm transmitting that
this is to be held
between these two fingers,
let alone
counterfactuals, like,
here's what you do
if your hand is slippery.
But but by bodily posture,
including vocal box bodily posture,
we can have an integrated account of
mimicry, skill transfer
again, transfers playing
way too
strongly into a transmission view, but
skill resonance or something similar
that helps recognize
the cognitive entities learning process
then.
DEAN: Okay, well,
I want to take what you're saying,
but I'm going to put a little bit
of a weird flex on it
because I want to try to combine
Blues PIN and Remi's pin and Daniel's
pin into one kind of question
that comes back to the paper.
So like the last
5 minutes of the conversation
has been focused on
the back of
and as typing
when it pertains
to language and communication
and blue bringing mimicry and is a
is a form of as person
who a lot of the emphasis in the paper
which is on the art
of communication and language.
DEAN: So here's my question.
I went back and read the paper again
and I caught myself asking,
DEAN: what do I hear
when I'm reading something?
Or I'm listening to someone?
What do I hear
as both processor and the producer?
As
we mentioned off camera, an arranger
of something being signaled,
which I'm picking up on and decoding.
So
rather than just leave it
there a part that for a second
because I think that's that
the the of what I want to ask
as a processor
and a producer as an arranger,
I can hear things in mono,
I can hear things in stereo,
I can even hear things
if I go to my Apple Music
in spatial audio.
DEAN: So
that is a field of affordances,
a question as opposed to a source
DEAN: of affordances question
And if I only limit myself
to the source,
I'm going to be asking
all the above type questions,
right?
So if I want to stay in the as of
if I want to be able
to hold up to things
at once,
at a minimum, the stereo or the spatial,
that's when I get into the ecological,
even if it's
specific ecological because I'm not
collapsing down to a single source
as my point of contact,
which then asks leads me to ask the fact
that communication
can be formed as an of types, meaning
mono stereo or spatial
mimicry interrogation.
DEAN: The fact that it can be broken out
DEAN: into those things, does that introduce
self production into the self processing
in your paper?
Because I know there's a heavy emphasis
on the above on the processing,
but I wonder if you keep the as
when blue brings it up
or when Daniel brings it up.
If we're
if we're keeping an eye on that,
even a specific ecological level,
are we not, when we hear something,
producers as well.
FRIEDMAN: What are we producing?
DEAN: I have no idea.
But I know I hear something
even when I read what you're typing.
I'm not just hearing the tap any tap,
I'm hearing something.
DEAN: We are product
produced,
we are produce like it's changing.
I'm hearing that
not
reading the.
So if I incorporate that,
what am I doing?
And I'm not the expert on communication,
so I wonder what the expert
can tell me about them.
TISON: Yeah, that's a good question.
Um,
yeah.
TISON: I'm not sure what to say about.
FRIEDMAN: Luc first and then we'll continue.
KNIGHT: So I wonder if what you're hearing,
FRIEDMAN: Dean,
has anything to do
with the internal monologue.
So like,
as you are reading something,
then you are also hearing something.
And so it's like there's this internal,
I mean,
like I have a very I'm a talker person
and so I like
I have
strong internal monologue
like all the time running like through
even getting ready in the morning.
KNIGHT: Okay, I need to get my shoes
and get my purse
and my keys and I have to pack my lunch.
And like all these things
like that happen.
So I'm constantly hearing that like,
as if I'm saying it maybe to myself,
even though I'm not speaking, but,
but I wonder what you know.
So I definitely am a producer
of whatever I am reading.
KNIGHT: Like I reproduce it.
I reproduce it though, right?
So I have in my own
mind my own internal monologue.
But I wanted to like
I know not
everyone has this internal monologue
and so so what is it then?
The same for the people that don't
perhaps have this internal monologue.
I mean, maybe they carry
around a picture of all the things
that they need
to get ready in the morning. So yeah.
DEAN: Justin Yeah.
And I think you bring up a good point.
Is it a monologue?
Is it a stereo log?
Is it a Quadra Phonic log
for some people?
I mean,
I mean, there was an availability
way back when, maybe
even before some of you were born,
there was Quadra Phonic Sound.
I remember that album in Quadrant Phonic
Sound and like
to my simple years, I didn't understand
what that even meant.
DEAN: Just because
they were able to break it out
into four parts, didn't didn't change
DEAN: what I was producing and processing.
So for the fact that we can type it
like that,
like not tape it up and literally
turn it into tapes, is the part
where I don't really have the background
to be able to explain
how that that ability
that field of affordances
as opposed to
examining this
as a single source of affordances
changes the the communication game
because it doesn't it
certainly does speak to mimicry
and what we can and cannot pick up.
DEAN: It certainly speaks to Daniel's point
about about what happens when
when layers
appear and disappear
because we narrow down
what we're picking up on versus
have have both of our ears working,
even though we think it's our eyes
that are doing all the skating.
Right.
So again, I'm not I'm not trying to ask
the impossible question.
I'm just
curious in the sense of producer
and processor
and what that arrangement is
dependent upon, what
what the because Dan,
you brought it up in
in the last livestream
circumstances matter
so but as a hearer
I wonder I wonder if we if we
if we know enough about ourselves
to really be able to,
to, to
give this anything more than it is,
DEAN: as Rami kindly pointed out in the paper,
give this more than
sort of a big roadmap deal.
If we if we are taking context
into consideration.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you.
Let me.
TISON: Yeah, I think the discussion
about the internal monologue
FRIEDMAN: is really interesting.
And there's a lot of things
that you said that
that I think really interesting.
But I want to go back to the
idea of the monologue.
And
there are some people who believe
that, like Chomsky, you believe that
language is not even for communication.
It's about structuring thought.
TISON: And so there's there are people
who believe that
the language is, first
and foremost
something that
is a property
of the structure of our thoughts
and not a property
of systems of communication and
so there's this idea that like the
the the
inner monologue comes first
and comes the communication
of this inner monologue in the
in communication.
So we have this basic that is once a
what's more inherent
in the transmission view
that we have our train of thought.
TISON: We are we have our
in our speech that we that
we have in our heads.
TISON: And then
we translate this in our speech, in
overt speech that is then
taken by somebody else.
And I think that this gets
the priorities wrong.
And between outer
speech and inner speech
and there's been
a lot of work in the philosophy by
Wilfred Sellers and by others
in in psychology, like if you go ski,
we say that
the first form of speech is overt speech
that is then internalized in in
that becomes like
that, that becomes inner.
TISON: But first,
in the beginning,
there's only overt speech.
A child that learns language
does not have an inner speech.
There is only outer speech
that is expressed directly
the child's speech.
The child
then do things with his words
in its environment
and does not directly, automatically
as the
corresponding inner
monologue in its head.
And there's a process
TISON: that's really interesting.
TISON: I think that is
where we see that beginning to happen,
where the child speaks to itself alone,
when there's nobody else around.
And so
there's this transition
where language is used
in communicative interaction.
And at some point
the child use language alone.
And there's a question of why,
why does it do?
And I think that our view
of communication is really
interestingly linked with use of
of the inner
monologue as self cueing
or self regulation.
TISON: And so the child can
actually regulate.
TISON: It's still about for a dance
when it's alone,
when there's nobody else around.
And in time this in the outer
zone for this outer monologue but alone
monologue
becomes overt because the child learns
to not necessarily produce
the sound that correspond
to the producing of these acts.
And there's there's
this integration that's
there is this internalization of
our third discourse
that becomes in our discourse.
TISON: And there's a lot of
cute anecdotes about that.
My nephew is a I have a nephew,
the son of my
TISON: my sister
and is like when is
is about to go to sleep.
He's in his bed.
And every night is like rehearsing
the events
that happen in in the day
and you seeing like the
the comments that that the rules
the norms that he heard in the
oh I don't have to do that
I must do that.
TISON: And so he's like, we're you
TISON: what happened in the day?
So this outer monologue
when he's alone in his bed
is like the beginning of inner thought.
We're seeing is starts
out in the open and
at some point this
this outer
monologue will become internalized
and we won't hear the he's his thoughts
out in the open.
But I think
that's like the process that it takes.
TISON: And there's also the idea another point
that we, for instance, when we read,
usually we read silently,
so we read
what's written
and we have the corresponding
inner monologue.
But it's known that in ancient times
when people were reading,
usually they were reading
automatically aloud,
loud, loudly, and it took a training
in order
to be able
to read without speaking the words.
TISON: And so, so like in middle age
and I'm not perfectly sure it's
if it's certainly accurately we should
verify it.
But I believe that's that's true.
And it seems that they heard that.
So it seems that
first there's the outer monologue,
the outer dialog,
and then there's the outer monologue,
and then there's the inner monologue
that comes after that.
TISON: And I think that's more the
the true direction of priority
between inner
monologue and other monologue
flow.
KNIGHT: So I just
have a cute anecdote
about, about learning, learning to talk.
So I have two kids
and they're super different.
My son did as your nephew did me
like would be in his crib
talking to himself,
talking to his stuffed
animals and kind of recreating events
in a similar way.
He also babbled a lot like a lot of like
just always bluff above about like
just saying
nothing from the time he was tiny
and has an incredible vocabulary.
KNIGHT: I mean, now he's six,
but people are like,
wow, how old is this kid?
KNIGHT: I mean, he's reading at three
and just is like very, very verbal.
And my my daughter is super different.
So she did not really babble,
but she signed like crazy.
And they both went to the same school.
They both teach them
the same signs like say,
milk and cracker and cheese
and you know, bathroom
and all the things.
KNIGHT: So like
they both went to the same daycare,
same environment,
and she picked up the signing
KNIGHT: much more than my son ever did.
Has maybe one or two signs.
She's like 20.
Like, I had to go learn the signs
and before she could sign,
she would just like stand
in the kitchen and scream,
like just unable to communicate
whatever it was that she wanted.
KNIGHT: And it's so odd.
Like,
they're just like two
totally different kids.
KNIGHT: But she when she was learning Chinese,
I had a parent teacher conference
with the two
and they're both in learning
Chinese now.
They're in private school
and they've been learning
for like eight years.
So when she was first starting to learn,
she wouldn't speak in class.
And the teacher and I had a conference
and the teacher said like, Oh,
I am concerned about your daughter.
KNIGHT: She doesn't participate in class.
Like she doesn't have to take Chinese.
It's not mandatory.
If you wanted to put her
in a different class
and she could have a silent
reading grade
and I was like, Oh, so it occurred to me
like and I knew that she and,
and because she didn't babble
and like I would,
somebody handed her a lollipop.
KNIGHT: She was like two
KNIGHT: and she said, Say thank you.
And she did the same for it.
But, but,
I mean, she really did not speak
would not form clear words
unless she knew
she could see them perfectly.
And so I said at a tutoring
with the Chinese tutor,
like just twice, three times.
And then it began,
like she was like listening.
KNIGHT: Can I repeat this to my engage
with this word correctly.
And she just was very more
much more careful in that.
But both kids,
as soon as they could talk,
talked in their sleep like crazy.
So Anyway, there's like kids start
like stories.
FRIEDMAN: The development of the self cueing
and self speaking is very interesting.
Even earlier on
in behavioral analysis and behaviorism,
like in B.F.
Skinner's work, there's extensive
exploration of how covert
monologues and covert
speech and societies of mind.
And then I guess more recently
it's become
better understood
how electrical activity in the body
and in the brain are still
initiated during covert speech like.
FRIEDMAN: It's not an audible speech,
but actually in various ways
it still is embodied.
And then this question of reading
perhaps is another area
where we're talking about
in this language area,
what is similar or different
with listening
to speech, participating in speech
audibly?
Is it different if it's read or Braille?
How does the modality
and the media influence
some of these things you
and
DEAN: again.
DEAN: I think the proportions of two ears
to one mouth
is something
that we need to kind of really
hold on to
in this idea of single source
and monologue versus
what potentially is a stereo log
in a field of affordances
as opposed to a single source.
I don't know why why we've been
I don't know what advantages
are given by having
an ability to hear in stereo, but
it must be
better than having a single year
or a single receipt,
a single reception site.
DEAN: And yet we we don't have two mouths.
So again, I think it's understandable
why from a
transmission point of view,
the deliverer standpoint,
we always collapse to a source,
a single source.
But if we
flip that
and now think about it
from the receiving standpoint,
how does that
how does that change our sense of what
communication is?
Because
it doesn't change
if I cover one of my years
or if I have an earbud in
and it cancels.
DEAN: And yet something
fundamentally must change
in terms of communication
DEAN: and the joint action,
even if it's monologue in my own head
versus dialog or trialogue
required to log.
Now again,
I haven't done any research
to try
to try to
figure out
what other people have done in terms
of looking at that.
But to your point, though, Renee,
in terms of
let's get this,
you can get past transmission.
DEAN: We're getting trying
to get past the idea
of what is being delivered
and being trying to gain a deeper
appreciation of what is being heard.
So blue.
I'll tell you a little story
I have a loquacious son
is in his thirties now,
but he's actually, as he's
gotten smarter and wiser, speaks less
like a occasionally
he gets out of a developing words
silence
that could serve an entire community.
DEAN: And I find that really fascinating.
I don't have to comment on it.
It's just you notice that as people know
more, they maybe they sign more,
maybe they find other ways
to to make their point.
And it goes back to that timing
your take thing.
So yeah.
FRIEDMAN: Great.
There's so many
references like the true way
is the one that can't be spoken of or
those who do do
and those who can't teach
all these kinds of funny,
you know,
poking fun at different archetypes
and so on.
And how that's related to wisdom.
The two
ears and one mouth,
which you've been referencing
throughout the conversations
and the Quadra Phonic sound.
FRIEDMAN: Quadrophenia, I'm sure, was amazing.
DEAN: From.
FRIEDMAN: It.
FRIEDMAN: It is true that the enrichments
and the spatial nature
of heard sounds, soundscapes
is it's like something that can't be
turned off.
Like the receiver.
All of our receiving is bilateral
visual
nostrils and smell
proprioceptive is heavily multilateral,
but it has a coarse bilateral symmetry.
But
the mouth,
as our action states,
needs generative
cohesion.
Perhaps just a just so story,
but I don't know
of any cases where there are
now there are some bodily
sounds that are bilateral,
like perhaps the
vibration of a cricket.
FRIEDMAN: So it's not
FRIEDMAN: that like
FRIEDMAN: sound production can't be bilateral.
TISON: Right?
FRIEDMAN: It's just that wherever sound production
is localized on the sender, when we
when we highlight content
in its transmission,
where does that account begin?
What has to begin with the content
and the representation in the sender?
And then you could ask
whether it was fully
or partially
or deceptively recognized
by the recipients, potentially
when we censor the
recipients action,
but even calling them
a recipient kind of
puts them on to a back foot.
FRIEDMAN: We're just centering
the agents engagements ecologically
and they're interfacing
with fields of affordances.
Then we we do see that
stereophonic enrichments
of everything.
And no matter how narrow or
how many, Shannon bits
or kolmogorov bits,
it doesn't really matter
because it's going to be unpacked
in a generative model that in aspects
that aren't and don't need to be
in the signal and hence
aren't or don't need to be in account
of the signaling.
DEAN: Just think
DEAN: I'm trying to bring back the inference
and to the active inference here,
because the active part
is definitely the transmission piece.
So thank you for for reinforcing that.
But I do
I do wonder when we do
bring the inference back,
why are our sensing
affordances are those bilateral forms?
There must be some advantage to that.
And so is it.
DEAN: As Blue pointed out, because of as not
just the heavy emphasis on the out?
Well,
what was the product of my transmission?
How am I pulling in this communication?
And what advantages are there
to not getting strung out
or hung up on the mono log?
The single source.
FRIEDMAN: One thing that makes me think about
is in caricature disinfo
representations of bug vision,
insect vision.
It will look like
they're seeing many separate cells,
whereas if
one were just to take a breath
and think about their own
visual experience,
we don't see two fields of you,
so it's like not really making sense
why an insect would see multiple.
FRIEDMAN: So the visual field, because there's
no objects out there.
We have all of these different ways
that we can talk about
how we know
that we're
experiencing an integrated
generative model
like the blind spot,
the differences
in visual acuity,
in the peripheral vision, color
vision in the periphery,
ocular motorcycle aids,
in the way that attention
is suppressed ordering secreting
so that it's not causing us nausea.
FRIEDMAN: All these features are really important,
and they point beyond a photon
transmission view of vision into this
generative stereophonic vision.
And then in the audio setting,
having multiple
aural orifices
and also even covering them up
like they're still transduction
through the skull and so on.
We are also seeking to flesh out
a generative
model of sounds in our environments.
FRIEDMAN: So if we cover our ears
like that, proprioception
will help us understand that
even if something sounds kind of quiet,
FRIEDMAN: we actually
we can recognize that
it's still a loud noise.
Or if we have one ear in a pillow,
we could recognize
that something is happening,
even though if it is being heard
differently on both sides.
So having multiple sensors
is very compatible
with a unified
generative model experience
because it forces
one to abstract
beyond any sensor reading.
FRIEDMAN: If you have one midline thermometer,
then that's your point.
Estimate for temperature.
Or you could have like a Gaussian blur.
Like I'm just less
confident about the temperature further
from my one central sensor.
But maybe I'm
maybe it's a tight Gaussian,
maybe it's very broad,
but this is the best estimate.
Why would I have any
other estimate centered anywhere else
when you have two thermometers?
FRIEDMAN: Now, there's a generative
modeling question
about whether it's
going to be a Gaussian
with a peak in the middle
or whether you're going to have a peak
more on one side
and have it
just go through the other
depending on those sensor readings.
But at that point,
you're ending up with some distributions
which if we think of that distribution
as like what is experienced,
as like
maybe the product of the sensing process
that distributions enrichment
is of a different type
and yet of a different simplicity
then any number of sensor readings
in terms of what
their raw information are.
FRIEDMAN: So it seems very relevant this to ears,
one mouth
not just for listening
twice as much as we speak,
but for
listening twice as actively as we speak
or something like that.
What do you think about sensors?
TISON: Rami
Yeah, I think that
you you explained it well.
It's
yeah, I think it's useful,
as you said, to have multiple sensory
channels that can be active,
because I think that's an argument
from how we and it's in its book
in 2013 book on predictive,
predictive mind.
I think he says that
if you have a
tribunal and you're
trying to establish the
culpability of the of a convict, you
you hope that you have multiple
independent sources of information,
because if these sources of information
are influenced each other,
you have a less reliable
I would say
I forget the world
at the moment in my years, unlikely
in English.
TISON: So I forget the word.
But you have a less reliable and
TISON: the information about
the about the the
the the case
so like it's useful from
from a reliability some point to to have
multiple independent
source of information
so so that may be an expression of why
we have that maybe an explanation of
the relative modularity
of of perception.
TISON: So there are
we know that there are
limits to that modularity,
but there is a
certain degree of independence
in the different sensory
modalities that we have.
So yes, about the two
here is that obviously,
I think maybe if we had
if our auditory sensory system
was only devised to
communicative interaction, maybe to
it would be okay to just have one here
when because
we could like
we know who's talking to us.
TISON: And so we, we can direct our,
our sensory
apparatus to do this communicative
signal.
But because we use our ears
not just to, to attuned
to a communicative interaction,
but also to know what's
in our surrounding, it's
really clearly more useful
to have that
to to have a greater reception
from from information
from anywhere around us.
So I maybe if if addition was only about
communication,
it would be okay to have just one ear.
TISON: But because we want to know
as precisely what's happening there
and at the same time know
what's happening there,
maybe it's it's it's there.
It has been more useful
to have these two here
two years on both sides.
So maybe there's something about that.
DEAN: That.
FRIEDMAN: You have one short note
and then Dean is
there are also
animals with anatomy
so that they can direct to their ears,
which is seemingly very analogous
to the ocular motor skating.
It's like an audio postcard
and it just the human form
outside of the ear wiggling,
which is maybe slightly
vestigial representation of that.
But we have opted for a strategy
with fixed ear positioning,
but a mobile neck
which also makes a cage.
FRIEDMAN: So that's kind of our
low speed audio skating team.
DEAN: Yeah, I think the only advantage
FRIEDMAN: I could see to having two models
is that I could eat the French fries
and drink milkshake at the same time.
And I don't know what
that would be like,
just overpowering, but
what I think is
interesting is in the .2.1
blue brought up the idea of, so
how do we make sure that there's
a difference
between content and context?
DEAN: And I think whether it's two eyes,
two ears, two nostrils, whatever,
there must be some advantage to the form
because as I said
even if you cover one of those intakes,
it's not just a redundancy issue, it's
a recursion issue.
It creates that ability to see context
here, context and smell context.
I don't believe
we would have those things.
DEAN: And as I said,
DEAN: I think I'd get overwhelmed with context
and having both French
fries and milkshake,
it would just blow me up.
So but that that's just a statement
that says it's not self.
They do not give people to models.
It can be overpowering.
TISON: Well.
FRIEDMAN: One aspect might return us
to the question of composition analogy.
It seems like visual
composition and temporal composition
in music and in heard speech
as
speaking
in terms of generative models
have highly factor, sizable
or sparsely connected generative models
famously connected to like the where
and the
what streams in visual neuroanatomy.
And that's been explored
in some active inference papers
with awareness and whiteness as being
factor visible in the generative model
because it really is the case
that different layers
can host different. What's.
And so it makes sense to have
those two totally separate
taste and
smell which are
there are more midline,
though there are two nostrils.
I'm not totally sure on
whether there's like, you know,
one or two smell chambers or anything
composition of chemical bouquets
seems quite different,
like two paintings
that you like next to each other
or to songs in succession
that you like.
FRIEDMAN: Or it's a little bit different than to
smells or tastes sequentially
or composed.
And so maybe these more
sometimes called basil, sensory
or cognitive features
are less affable.
And this kind of relates to a cognitive
stack
where verbal
and symbolic communication is
like the tip of the iceberg.
Support it by
biological processes
that are differently or less affable
and at first only pointed towards
like through metaphors and speech,
butterflies in my stomach and so on,
but then
ultimately entirely inexpressible,
maybe with some stop in between,
like being able to express
through the body,
like what
it's like to do a certain
bodily position
or have a certain experience
or be in a certain physiological state.
FRIEDMAN: And
this kind of casts
a light on the transmission view,
complementing the ecological view,
the transmission view
is like down, propagating
symbolic communication
and seeking for that
to apply all the way on down.
Whereas a more bottom up and arguably
eco evo devo informed perspective
is grounded in the ecological setting
and then allows for
the crystallization
of symbolic processes,
including communicated
symbolic processes which
are aren't
they supposed to be the stronghold
of the transmission view?
FRIEDMAN: But then if even that phenomena
can be
captured within an ecological frame,
then there's an extremely strong basis
for the integrative cohesion
of an ecological view, as opposed to
an extremely piecemeal and
question begging transmission view
like we talked about.
So meiosis
and biosimilars, this in live stream 47.
So will we see
verb verbal communication and behavior
as something that is enabled
and with analogy,
but not the same as
cellular transduction?
FRIEDMAN: Or are we going to seek
a cellular transduction explanation
based on verbal behavior?
Let's return to some of our topics.
All right. Few areas to go blue.
Any thoughts?
Just any way you want.
KNIGHT: Yeah.
So I just wanted to follow up
on what you said.
And I just think that the beauty
of the ecological approach
to understanding communication
is that communication between cells, bit
semiotic representation or other,
and between
animals, maybe
with gestures, maybe interspecies
communication like, you know,
you tell your cat,
come here
and the cat comes or dog or whatever.
KNIGHT: So I think that that the ability
to model systems
like our systems is very important.
Like if,
if the transmission view
is not capable of representing
all of the situations
from cell
to cell communication
to human to dog communication, and,
and all along the line,
I think that maybe it's in the way
that the
ACP inactive in France
is still free and slick doesn't have.
But I mean
KNIGHT: it's across
any hierarchical temporal
cognitive scale.
I think that that the way
that we view communication
also needs to be broadly applicable.
FRIEDMAN: Yes, really.
TISON: So yeah, that's that's the aim.
But clearly
some people will say that
sophisticated linguistic communication
can thus be accounted for in terms of
in terms
of the
ecological communication, because,
as Daniel said,
the symbolic communication
characteristic of language
seems to be too removed
from the kind of basic interaction
described by the ecological approach.
So there's this like
there's a lot of work to be done
still to to really explain these
the high level
linguistic interactions
that we have in our
in terms of the, of the ecological
in active communication.
TISON: But yeah, there's another example of,
of communication,
as you
said, we can I come to me before a
communicative interaction between cells
but there's also
there's been the work
on communication between between plants
and how plants
perceive their their environment
in terms of affordances.
And there's been work on that.
And so
I think that
there's it's just to say
that there's a it's another
and another way in which we can develop
the ecological approach.
TISON: And it seems that
that if we yeah.
TISON: If any, any,
any organisms, that organism
that behaves in
the organism
will have a field
of that far dense and it seems that if
it wants to act on other organisms
in its environment,
it will act
in affecting its field about audience.
And it looks like
the kind of communication
that is at play
between trees, for instance,
which alerts each other about,
for instance,
the threats in the, in the forest
or sources of, of useful resources
in the, in the drone.
TISON: So these kinds of modifications of
of of of the yeah,
I don't know exactly the mechanism
by which these the these these
these communication take place,
but we can also see them
as modifications
of the field of affordances, of trees.
So I think that that was
when I saw that I was really
I thought it was really cool
that the trees
behaved at a really, really slower
timescale, obviously, but like behavior
when they go in the sand, like their
their roots in certain directions
and things like that,
we can see it as them
exploring their environment, them
reacting to a field of avoidance that
TISON: that they.
TISON: So obviously that
that's also
controversial because there's
all this debate
about the cognitive states of of plants
and do they have a consciousness
or a left thing.
But I think that we can see that
they probably have
something like a field of us audience
and it seems that they can
communicate with each other
via these modifications
of their field of avoidance
without us
having to say
that they are transmitting content,
which would be really weird
from the standpoint of a plant.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you. Blue.
So just like if you haven't
seen the plant robot created by the MIT
Media Lab, like,
FRIEDMAN: check it out
because the plant, like,
they connected it
to a set of wheels and a motor
and literally will wheel itself
back and forth from window to window,
like searching for sunlight.
So So, I mean,
when you modify
the field of affordances
of a plant,
it will
it will take advantage of
this affordances
for movement or any other kind of thing.
KNIGHT: And as to the complexity of
like linguistic communication, okay.
But like also like the complexity
of cellular communication, especially in
like developmental biology
and all of the growth factors,
signaling cues.
And I mean it's highly complex
and like the re
combinatorial aspect
is also incredibly crazy.
Like I think
it would take a lot to convince me
that linguistic communication
is more sophisticated or more advanced
than biological communication
in a developing organism.
KNIGHT: I'm not sold on that.
Thanks, Steve.
DEAN: We're making it.
And you
help me understand a little bit
more about the
the influence piece in the joint action.
If if I'm in Madrid,
a lot of people
who are trying to get my attention,
I'm not very I'm not
I don't speak Spanish very well,
just barely get by.
And so a lot of times
things are spoken to me and there is a
there seems to be a break
in terms of the amount of sensing I get.
DEAN: And so that joint action could you maybe
especially in the
in the light of that earlier
part where you talked about young kids,
they think
it appears
they're talking to themselves,
but they're talking to the world
and maybe
they're not influencing the world,
but they would like to.
Could you maybe talk about that
sort of sensing side
of that joint action?
TISON: Yeah.
TISON: So I think that what
kids that alone are doing they're nuts.
TISON: They learn to talk by talking
to each other
and affecting other persons.
But when they learn
to talk to each other, they're doing
they're they're influencing themselves.
I think that
that's the part about self cueing.
So what they're doing, they're,
they're modifying their own
field of affordances
with their, with their
this inner speech
and that's how they the
they they don't to self cue
and self-regulate themselves
by bringing some
some images in mind or things like that.
TISON: So that's the
I think that's what happens when the
when the child
learns to do to speak alone.
And there's obviously
a lot more to say about that
when there's.
So the question
of of the of different languages
when you're in another country
and you don't so you're spoken to
and you're not understanding correctly.
But you
you pick up some
some parts of what's said.
TISON: So I think that, um,
I think that
the, the learning of a language
is, often,
is often understood as the, the, the,
as the, as the learning a code.
So learning
a set of associations between
between
meanings and between forms
that can be either written or spoken.
But I think that in the
the approach that we're
we had been seeing here,
learning
the language is really more like
learning, learning a skill.
TISON: So you learn you're learning to
to speak
and learning
to understand
and interact correctly
in a given language
as you're learning to do
anything else,
TISON: you're learning to play a game,
you're learning to play hockey.
So our play soccer or whatever is the
the same kind of learning
and you're learning to interact
in that kind of game.
And probably there's a similarity
between various languages
and the because it's
there's, there's a similarity
and there's
like like very
I would
I could talk about Gideon Stein there
once, once again.
TISON: But like
there's this the various languages
resemble each other
TISON: because they have this
this family resemblance.
So because you have
this familiarity
with speaking in a language,
even when you're
in another place
where don't understand the language,
you have a basic grasp
of some of the structures of the game
that is being played.
And so from that context, you can get
understand some of the things that are
said, understand, understand
some of the things that are
expected of you
because you have this grasp
of what kind of game is played.
TISON: When we speak our language.
And so even if you're in in them
in another country,
when you don't speak the language
TISON: from the context
in which you find yourself,
you may be able
put some things together.
Obviously, if you're like
just in a place
with absolutely no context,
you're in a white room completely empty
and somebody is talking to you.
TISON: You have no context.
Probably you won't understand anything.
But if you're in that context
where you can understand
that in some games of of
there are some,
TISON: some goals that are that are in place
and some people around
you are trying to achieve some goal.
You can apply your understanding
of the game
that you play your own language
through this new language.
TISON: And so you can get some things
you can understand some things about
what's what's
what you have to do
and how you should behave
and how you can respond.
But I think that that's a better way
of understanding
the kind of limited
understanding that you have
in these kind of interactions
rather than in
you having a code of your language.
TISON: And then you try to apply this code
in this you I think that that then
TISON: the idea of learning a skill, learning
how to play a game is a better analogy
to understanding
how you come to learn a language
and how you come to apply this,
this knowledge
in other contexts where the language
that is spoken is not the same that you
that you're mastering.
DEAN: Does that kind of confirm that
it couldn't be content first,
that it would have to
DEAN: be context bound?
TISON: Yeah, in my view,
the context is a central element in
in in any communicative interaction
and in any cooperative
communicative interaction.
I think it's the it in the context
what the what
I call the context in the paper appears
as a shared field of audience.
So that's
the audience
that are present in the, in the, in the,
the environmental context
in which you find yourself in
with the other person.
TISON: And that's that's
just an element that often exists.
The communicative interaction
TISON: is a great,
great source of constraint
on the communicative interaction.
So yeah,
when you,
when you come to speak with somebody,
you're almost
never like in a absolutely free place.
You're always
in a restaurant in there,
in, I don't know, in the bus, in the
in the in the grocery store.
TISON: You're somewhere
there's this basic set of affordances
that are shared that you understand
that you can do this,
you cannot do that.
And this this set of constraints
offered by this charge feel about
really drives
and constrains
how the communicative interaction
will unfold.
So
I think that even
if you're in another country,
a friend,
the context will be hard to pick up.
TISON: But sometimes
TISON: there will be shared context
that you can get a grasp on
and that you can
that can.
So that can lead to a
I'm sorry, I'm losing my words
that can lead to an interaction that is
that is optimal.
FRIEDMAN: I brought it
in the physical Rosetta Stone
as a special case of of low
context asynchronous communication.
One can imagine
there would be a million
different contexts
by which the analysis of the stone
could have
accelerated, such as a person reading
any of them,
the rules or descriptions being enacted,
or a labeled image,
or any
number of contexts
that we would use to interpret
and act upon the texts that we read
in this setting
where
we were historically removed
from the creation.
FRIEDMAN: Then there's still
was residual context,
and it turned out that that was enough
to interpret the symbolic
materials.
But this
is not like the base communication case
that we
then need to see all communication
and all learning
and education of languages
and active
inference ontology
as being like a Rosetta Stone,
like the definitions of words
are not codes to crack.
They're like inside jokes
or ways of communicating a sports team
that have to do
with the context of the setting and
asynchronous
modifications in the environments,
especially symbolic asynchronous
modifications which are relatively new,
potentially existing in their
modern form for several hundreds
to several thousands of years,
depending on how we think about it.
Symbolic, asynchronous modification
is a low context communication,
whereas even the interpretations
of asynchronous symbolic communication
still uses and embodies
their context in the perception.
FRIEDMAN: So we know that we have
stereophonic communication
just because stereophonic,
even if we are getting
just a morse code symbol.
But
it is a
non-controversial here.
But interestingly,
it sounds like elsewhere
that we would want to think
about communication broadly
as being action oriented and embedded
rather than
kind of like reverse engineered
from the kinds of artifacts
that we have today
with quite literally computer codes
and other kinds of, you know,
Turing computers and so on.
FRIEDMAN: Okay.
TISON: I think that too often they explain
the idea is that
the ideas that I'm trying
convey really better than me
then, you know,
I'm not really fluent in English though.
Thank you for explaining better than me
the idea that I'm trying to say
thank you.
I appreciate it.
FRIEDMAN: And you wrote the paper.
And so it's unsurprising, it seems novel
and I couldn't say it in any other way.
KNIGHT: Even when you
speak English,
Daniel can still like better than than
you mean it more effectively.
The idea is that you're trying to convey
even when English
is your first language.
DEAN: Well.
FRIEDMAN: Context is non-fungible.
So I don't think that there can be
FRIEDMAN: a best or a final communication.
It's just like a best
or a final species
or state for an ecosystem to be in.
And I guess in the last
25 minutes or however,
now that our ecosystem
has been modified,
however it has been
in these conversations
and through reading and
opening up threads,
how will it
shape our field of affordances
and how will we
stream and play differently in.
DEAN: So I'm curious from all three of you
as a strategy,
if you want to get past monologue,
what do you do?
How many times do you play play in play?
So as an example of like a
real pertinent one, right now
the way that the livestreams
have been set up,
I've always been sort of a pre brief,
an introduction with the authors or play
and then a play, a debrief used to this.
DEAN: And so the communication is never left
as a, as a one off exercise.
DEAN: I just read the paper.
There's a, there's,
there is affordances set up to interact
with information
to be able to receive it
at multiple different time points.
Because I think in the one room
you said we could look at it
as slices of time,
but that's probably not
accurate in terms of the dynamic
that's in place.
DEAN: So
one of the things
the Active
Insurance Institute also does is has a
textbook group.
Now, I've not been
part of the text group, book group,
and I don't know whether they do it in
sets of three as well
to create that kind of triangulation
so that the interactions
of the communication doesn't become
monolithic or monastic
or here,
here's here
is the words
that have come down now off the mount.
DEAN: Accept them and start
start carrying them out.
Even though you don't have
a context, right?
Chiseling them into the stone
doesn't increase their priority,
at least if you don't have the context.
So what I'm curious about from
the three of you is
if you want to get past
instructional ism in terms
or if you want to get past transmission,
is there a basic requirement
to have multiple reinterpretations
or at least the opportunity
to reinterpret,
like just
from a communication standpoint,
do we must we have reflection
and time for that.
DEAN: We have to have time built in for that.
Or are we are we then bound to
a transmit state on
anybody can answer.
FRIEDMAN: Yes.
FRIEDMAN: Bloopers.
KNIGHT: So it's not
like in the way that we have reflection
like we have a pre brief
and then to the actual brief
and then
the reflection
time in the livestream series.
So, so not in that way
but but I do think that in this
in effective communication
is like reflection
as an essential component of that,
like communication
when you have a conversation,
it's shouldn't be about
just waiting for your turn to talk.
KNIGHT: I mean, there should be some reflection
of what
the other person is saying
in what you're saying back to them.
KNIGHT: It's like,
Hello, how are you doing today?
I want scrambled eggs.
Like if that was the conversation went,
it wouldn't be it wouldn't work, right?
So there
to be some element of reflecting back
what the other person is saying to you
in communication that's effective.
KNIGHT: It's not just this like Tower of
KNIGHT: disjointed blocks being built.
FRIEDMAN: Yes. For me.
TISON: Yeah.
TISON: I think
I think that
what you said is is interesting,
a really important element
TISON: of cooperative communication
is that when you're talking to somebody,
when you're in the dialog,
you have
to concede a part of your autonomy.
You have to
accept to be regulated
by the other person.
And that's, I think,
where some people who like
to talk past each other
and don't listen to each other,
an interaction
that happens that really offends
some friends don't like.
TISON: It seems like when when they're waiting
they're just waiting.
When they're listening,
they're just waiting
to see what they want to say.
So these don't like don't respect that
kind of pragmatic principle
of like you have to
to pay attention to what
the other person is saying
and to have a proper to have a correct
communicative interaction
us to concede the like,
you have to accept
that your field of performance
is regulated
by the person who's sucking through you.
TISON: You have to let yourself be
influenced, be constrained by either
by the person that was talking to you
just because you
you have to listen to it
and you have to
refrain from like turning away
and go go do something else.
So you have to like it's really
just accepting,
conceding a part of your autonomy.
And that's another idea from a De Paolo
as an active approach of language
where
there's been communicative interaction
in the, in any cooperative interaction.
TISON: But in
TISON: community of interaction particular,
you have to
write inhibit
a part of your field about for a dance
to participate
in this interaction and listen.
Because suppose that
what I'm saying is really boring to you
and you just want to go
eat your piece of cake
in the in the fridge
like us do in order to participate,
to maintain
the interaction,
you have to inhibit this.
TISON: There's that part to the solicitation
and to,
to, to
let me regulate your
your your field about for a dance.
And so there's this part of
like I concede that
I concede something
in order to maintain the interaction.
And when there is no no more interest
or I'm not able to to I don't want to
to be regulated.
And there's another solicitation
outside the interaction
that's more interesting to me.
But then I will leave the interaction.
But to maintain the interaction,
you have to have a and
a capacity of inhibition that
exit of executive
some form of
what would be called executive control
to be able to listen and take
what the person is saying.
If you don't have that, you're
just going to think about something else
and not let yourself be take
be constrained
by the coming captive
acts of the other person.
FRIEDMAN: So
back to Dean's
point about multiple art and multiplayer
communication and engagements
when we only have one communication,
then it can feel like a transmission
like the Rosetta Stone
transmitted from the past.
We don't get a dot two or a dot one
on the Rosetta Stone
structuring
learning groups
and other activities
and relationships and.
Co-operative communication
as something unfolding,
bumping into each other twice
says something about those particles
that bumping together just once
FRIEDMAN: dozens.
FRIEDMAN: It's almost like
when I say once there's an accident
twice as a coincidence
three times is a party or
something like that.
So especially with three,
because one, two, three,
there may be a enough
of a recurrent engagements
and interweaving
to support reflection and development
to de-emphasize
any single of those events,
because none of them are even half
of the total series of three.
FRIEDMAN: So none of them can even be
said to be a plurality or a majority
FRIEDMAN: if the .01 and two were to vote
to vote one of them out
or something like that.
And I think it does point towards
the reality of our continued interaction
with materials
and then towards structures
that allow us to engage naturally.
TISON: Remy
I think that what
communicating
in there repetitively
the same people,
what it achieves, it's,
it obviously it
shapes the generative
model, it aligns them in some ways.
So we come to share expectations
and share fields of affordances.
So it clearly eases
communicative interaction
because we have to communicate as much
when there's this tradeoff
between
if you have a lot of shared context,
you don't
have you don't
have to communicate as much.
TISON: And if you don't have
a lot of social context,
you have to communicate
more to, to, to, to a
yeah, as a, a useful interaction
to have a productive interaction.
And so what I think we, we have done is
we have like aligned
our different models in ways
that helps us understand
each other better than
we did at the beginning.
TISON: For instance, we can
refer to things that.
We said in the past
we can say, Oh, well,
when you said that.
So I think that's relevant now.
And so we can make
can point to relations, to things
that that we said earlier.
So there's this
there's this continual
easing of communication.
And when you have repetitive,
communicative interaction with somebody,
that's I think that I think is
why we can come to believe that people
we are living with,
we can read each other's mind
with or without talking,
because there is so much shared context
that something can happen
and it can make us think some
something that is shared without us
even saying anything.
TISON: So there's this this context come to be
really complex and really,
really deep.
And so yeah, interacting repetitively
obviously is, is communication.
FRIEDMAN: Okay, so we can
meet multiple times due preparation,
engagement and reflection
before, during and after a communication
and structure communication
so that there are multiple
such kind of peaks, troughs
we can talk about aligning or
synchronizing
in the general synchronous sense,
not making it identical,
but rather
coordinating our generative models
through perception and learning.
As you mentioned, helps us understand
each other better.
FRIEDMAN: Like a goal of a communication
could be epistemic
let's get to know each other
and it could also have an element
of pragmatic value,
like let's take epistemic action
to find out
if a collaboration is relevant here.
And then
going to engage
in these pragmatic actions.
TISON: Remmy
Yeah, and I think that a lot of
interaction
that we share in our academy can
a linguistic in advanced societies
really often
look like transmission interaction.
So we're seeing things
that we're thinking to each other,
but I think that is epistemic
or communicative
in terms of transmission
is a communicative
transmission
interactions are are the way they are
because they are explicit
aims of the interaction
in which we are engaged.
TISON: That is,
TISON: we are transmitting content
now when we're talking to each other
because
in a way
that that's the goal of the interaction.
But in other contexts like it's
because we have come get practices
that we have developed
that we can have these these goals
that can drive an interaction.
And if we're at the grocery store,
if we're in other context,
we're doing something
with something else.
TISON: But when we're in academic contexts,
often the goal of the interactions is
talking about
transmitting some, some,
some contents, transmitting some, some,
some theories,
for instance,
explaining theories,
explaining arguments.
And so these interactions.
We look at them and we're like,
Oh, that's clearly there's
we're transmitting content
when we're talking.
But the idea is that
this is really a small subset of,
the cases of communicative interaction
that we engage in in everyday life,
and we take these as paradigmatic cases
of communicative interaction
when they are really
the pinnacle of the
the linguistic civilization.
TISON: We're in a really rarefied
context where academic discussions are
not what we do in everyday settings.
When we talk to each other
and we we do this, it's
because it's an explicit
aim of our interaction
now that we do this. But in other cases,
in many in
most cases, when we speak to each other,
that's not the aim.
TISON: The explicit aim is not to transfer
some information or talk about theories.
It's about doing things together.
And now we're doing something together.
We're talking about active inference,
but it looks as if it can be understood
in in terms of content
sharing and content transmission.
But that's because it's the goal
of our interaction.
It's that
because it's
the nature of communication.
TISON: And I don't know if I'm being clear
yet.
FRIEDMAN: Dingyadi or Henry.
DEAN: I just I think
I don't want to put
my philosopher's cap on, but I will.
Just briefly,
I think we use language of communication
to save time.
It's an exploitation strategy.
And so I think when we put a 13 week set
of parentheses
around a learning moment or opportunity,
we oftentimes get it,
get the cart ahead of the horse.
DEAN: We don't
we don't see the pragmatics
DEAN: because we're busy transmitting.
And what ends
up happening
is the plan forward that affordances,
that exploitation
or optimization or savings of time
jumps ahead of practice
to participate in the permeate.
Now we can see that's a luxury.
But is it
if we don't respect the fact that people
maybe don't necessarily learn as well
when they're handed the plan,
as opposed to
given an opportunity to build
one or form
one themselves through preparation,
participation, permeation.
DEAN: We could go away from this live stream
and each of us
could literally now design a better plan
as opposed to
DEAN: Remi came to us with a plan,
what really came to us,
what was a sketch.
And then we perhaps
participated and permeated.
Now
that the sophistication
of whatever comes out of that
in terms of a goal for each one of us
is orders of magnitude greater
because somebody didn't say, Oh,
well, I've only got 13 weeks.
DEAN: I don't have the luxury
to be able to be pragmatic about this.
So there, I'll take my hat off again.
I don't mean to sermonizing,
but I think when we actually feel
what it's like to let the plan
naturally evolve and become
a part of the ecology
as opposed to driving the ecology,
the single source,
it changes everything.
DEAN: And over and over again,
every time we have one of these
three set live streams, it reinforces
what you could do.
And again,
you don't even have to be on the the zoo
as long as you get over
the amount of time
to see and sense
what it's like to prep, participate.
And I think the most important
one of all stick around for the Permian
because that's
where the real nuggets seemed.
DEAN: Daniels metaphor of icebergs,
things float
to the surface
when you give it enough time.
But I understand
there's also a 13 week window,
and when paying thousands of dollars
to just sit in your class and come on,
exploit the daylights
out of
your communication,
and I just don't know
that people don't realize
that they're cutting off their noses
to spite their they're learning.
FRIEDMAN: So
interesting a lot
their permeation letting it pervade
our generative model or percolate,
letting those messages be passed,
letting that ripple or the perturbation
take effect
slower and deeper levels.
And it is really a challenge
when the logistical and transmission
aspects of communication
are scaffolded.
And those are like the metadata fields
that have to be filled out, the boxes
that have to be checked,
and they can feel constraining.
FRIEDMAN: Yet
simply removing them
is not a positive solution.
And so the path of least action
for many learning scenarios
is to replicate the prior.
DEAN: You're.
FRIEDMAN: Over the decades a professor
who might teach the
same class in the same way.
And there's pros and cons to that.
In fact, some of the most
enlightened learning communities
have like a vibrancy that transcends
an almost ironically static
learning experience.
Like, we all read this thing.
So it's not that
that I think the mode of communication
and cooperation
in education that we're exploring here
means that
every single experience
is going to be like
some kind of full attention,
transformative depth psychology.
FRIEDMAN: I think it would feel more
normal and natural
and just like participating in
a cool ecosystem
that works with that individual's
situation, what else can we add
or where can we go?
Where is active inference
in all of this?
Where do you see active inference?
Not like, you know,
what are your intentions
with my child, but
where
is active inference in
your further research agenda?
TISON: Me
I think it gives the,
the like
all encompassing
framework and
yeah, the, the,
the, the abstract ness
of their framework
allows us to apply
it to, as we said, light,
come and get the communication
between cells
and communication between like
countries or, or groups of individuals
with this multi-scale
property of active and friends
I think is really useful in the,
in enabling us to describe
communicative interaction
between these various kinds of
of free their minimizing
yeah.
TISON: Agents and
so there's this that
that's useful I think that
yeah the, the,
the learning mechanisms that are
that are at work in active inference
are really useful
also to explain our come together
in direction is conducted
in our repeated
communicative interaction
can lead to
that form of synchronizing
of the generated model
as has been explored by Vasyl
in that paper and in 2020.
TISON: I think so
I think that's
that's really useful
and there's a lot of,
a lot of things that
that I
think we can
take from
the active inference framework.
And yet
the idea that's all
I think this fundamental intuition
is that all,
all action is free
and there are minimization
that's trivial that that's meant.
But I think there's a pragmatist
insights in active inference
that we can use to to,
to support the
pragmatic view of communication.
TISON: Yeah.
TISON: That everything that an organism does
TISON: it does it to minimize the three
and active inference is no different.
And a communicative active inference
as a form of active inference
also aims to minimize
the free energy of an overturned
down is them.
And so when an organism tries, it
finds itself in a situation where it's
there's a lot of free energy
or there's a lot of error of prediction.
TISON: It will try to
engage it in its endeavor intervening.
It's an environment
in order to bring itself
back in the available in, viable states.
And so all these ideas
and when we apply them to communication,
I think they lead
not necessarily by implication,
but I think the
there's a path to these ideas, true
to the
pragmatic view of
communication, the idea
that communication is another form of
is just a mechanism of regulation
of organisms
in order to minimize their free energy.
TISON: I think
there's this kind of basic biological
and understanding
of the behavior of organism.
TISON: I think it leads us more toward
the pragmatist view of communication
rather than toward the
the more informational
or transmission view that is
that is more at home in our
like really
highly advanced and complex
linguistic interactions.
And I think that this like
basic biological framework
is a good place.
TISON: Try to understand
communication in the pragmatist.
FRIEDMAN: You a
very nice answer
all I'll read a comment from Stephen
and then we can give a thought on it
as well as provide
some closing thoughts.
So Stephen wrote
Explicit aims
of interaction
are important and can be invisible.
Thus communication appears
to be based on transmission.
Should we identify the context
through the affordances or via
naming the water
like the water we swim in?
FRIEDMAN: That is is the context
and the explicit
aims apparent via the affordances?
Or is there a special source
FRIEDMAN: that flavors
the cultural waters
in which we are swimming?
Yeah,
Steve, special sauce.
DEAN: Real quick on that.
I think what maybe you did build on
what Remy just said.
I think
perhaps active inference opens up
that space.
It's to the
to the idea of a special sauce.
It doesn't guarantee
that there will be one,
and it certainly doesn't promise.
But what it does do is it says,
what are the possibilities within this?
Not just what are we collapsing down to?
I mean, throughout this series,
I've been talking a lot about,
well, we can't leave the absolutes,
the things that we've experienced
out of this equation.
But I think what the
what I think
the active inference affords is that
those relativities
in those those entanglements
and those entanglements
always to be determined
can be moved towards
and and maybe accepted
with with more abundance
if we use active inference.
DEAN: But that's just my optimistic take on.
FRIEDMAN: Do you have any other closing words
before we hear some final thoughts
from the others?
Excellent. Okay.
Blue or Remy with some final thoughts.
How's this?
How will it permeate with you?
TISON: Okay, so I'll go ahead.
So, yeah, I was really happy
to have the chance
to talk about the paper with you.
I think that one of the
most important things
that I would take home is that now
I have a really salient solicitation to
see the Planet Robot
in action.
So like
at the
second that I close
the Zoom meeting, I'm
going to go see that.
TISON: That's really something
that I taking
from the citizen discussion.
But yeah, no,
it was really interesting
to see
different perspectives,
different backgrounds and
what, what
these different
differing backgrounds
can bring to a discussion that is,
I think that was really enlightening
for me and I was really happy to to be
there.
KNIGHT: Just say thanks for coming.
I mean, we really enjoyed
this discussion.
And for me,
I think what will permeate is like the,
KNIGHT: you know, everything I think about now,
I just think about
how can I model this
in terms of active influence?
And I feel like this paper will,
you know, influence
maybe the way that I think about
communication,
which is a big part of modeling,
active influence
period, especially like
in a multi-agent dynamical system.
KNIGHT: So I think I will probably leverage
the psychological approach
in the way that I think about it
going forward.
So I appreciate the opportunity
to learn about it.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome.
My closing thought.
What I'm left with here is active
inference as about affordances
is about the content of the model
is about affordances,
and active inference is an affordances.
It allows us to realize epistemic
and pragmatic value today
and in the future.
And in that way
we can see it as a gripper and gripped.
Just like we could talk about the hand
as gripper and gripped,
whether it's holding hands
or grabbing an object, and especially in
this thought to some very nice points
added on language as gripper and gripped
and contextualizing
this kind of breakaway verbal community
of research and scholarly education
and academia,
and recognizing that breakaway community
and skill
as something that's crystallizing
out of a much more inclusive
and pragmatically oriented niche.
And I think that will be a win win
framing because it will help ground
what can be abstract
and lofty discussions and also
elevate and bring what
bring attention
and support
to some areas and types of communication
that are absolutely natural
in field of affordances
view and the ecological view,
but are not always respected.
FRIEDMAN: So highly unsure
like a symbolic transmission view
and the closing image
for me is making the source underwater.
I'm just imagining it's like,
I don't know, SpongeBob SquarePants
or someone's
trying to cook
and make the sauce,
but we're adding things.
And it's more
just like happening
in this diffusive space.
And in a way,
all kitchens are in fluids.
FRIEDMAN: That's why we can smell
what we're cooking.
But it's different enough
that the sauce stays in the pan.
And I think the social
and action of active
inference is when the sauce is spilling
out of the pan.
All right,
Remy, you're
always welcome
back, so hopefully
you'll share some developments
in this line.
Good luck with the rest of your work.
DEAN: Thanks to. You.
FRIEDMAN: All right. Very well.
TISON: Bye.